- [Jim] Hey, everybody.
I am Jim.
- [Vlad] I'm Vlad.
- [Jim] So today we're gonna
talk about coding an MCP server
for Amazon Aurora.
For those of you that have
never been to a Code Talk,
this is gonna be a little different.
You're gonna sit here and watch me code
for the next hour, right?
So it's, I'm a bad typist
giving you that heads up
right from the beginning.
So I'm gonna use Kiro to do
a lot of this stuff for me.
Otherwise, you'd be watching
me having typos constantly.
But let's keep this interactive.
Let's turn this into a giant
paired programming exercise.
So if you see me making typos,
shout it out. It's okay.
I won't be offended if
you see me making a typo.
It'll make things go faster.
And if you have questions,
let's have them, as they're coming along.
Vlad's gonna be walking
around with the microphone.
So let's just keep it interactive
while we're doing things.
So what we're gonna
talk about today is MCP.
Its already Tuesday.
You probably have had a
few sessions about MCP,
model context protocol.
This is a universal
framework in order to be able
to expose out your backend
data to LLMs for gen ai.
It is still a new and
maturing specification.
It's only a year old. Got
released about a year ago.
Latest spec just came out last week.
Haven't had a chance to deep dive on it,
but there's a lot of cool
security stuff in there
that I'm excited about.
Because I thought that was something
that was missing before,
as we were thinking about
how do we push this into production,
into exposing things externally
outside of your internal infrastructure.
We're gonna leverage one
of the AWS MCP servers,
the Aurora Postgre MCP server.
There's a bunch of them around.
A lot of different services.
They're all on GitHub.
Feel free to download and play with them.
MCP really is made up of a bunch of tools.
You're exposing out a bunch
of services out to the LLM
and it gives you an API in
order to be able to do that.
And it's more in free text, right?
So really how the LMS
determine what those tools do
is by the code, by the description
that you type there in
human readable format.
What you type there really
matters in a lot of cases.
We're gonna use Aurora Postgre.
So when we talk about Amazon Aurora,
we have Aurora Postgre,
Aurora MySQL, and Aurora DSQL.
We're gonna focus on Aurora Postgre.
But the stuff we're gonna
do today really would work
across any of the Postgre variants.
Even open source community Postgre.
We're not doing anything
specifically Aurora.
Some of the MCP server stuff
uses the data API for it.
But the code we're writing
is really Postgre code,
not necessarily Aurora code.
We're gonna leverage Bedrock.
Again, this is probably
something that you're seeing
in a lot of sessions this week,
but we're gonna use Bedrock
to be able to host our models.
So what we're building,
we're gonna start with a real
basic Strands application
that it is gonna be an
entertainment hub where just...
Right.
And then we're gonna build an MCP server
that has two tools in it.
It's gonna have a tool called
Get, get movie characters,
and get actor roles.
Those are gonna pull data from
an Aurora Postgre database.
And then Strands is going
to use Bedrock for the LLM
in order to be able to use that data.
The MCP client we're
leveraging from Strands, right,
is we're gonna start with
a simple time MCP server
so we can tell what time it is.
Just those are one of
those sample MCP servers
that actually end up becoming
really, really useful.
Because LLMs don't know what time it is,
so if you start asking
questions about time,
it needs to know what the current time is
for different things.
So if you wanted to say,
show me all the log
history for the last hour,
it kind of needs to know what time it is
for different things like that.
So it needs a source of truth for that.
So it ends up being fairly useful
for a lot of different things.
We're gonna use our data model.
This is from the IMDB dataset.
I created a data model
that's more of a traditional
normalized data model.
Foreign keys, something
that you would expect
in your old school legacy OLTP databases.
So there's gonna be some joints, right?
So this way it's not just
the simple single table.
It needs to think a
little bit in order to,
how do I get this data out?
And it's some of it's ugly data, right?
Of just being, how does it get out, like,
when some certain things are
null, what does that mean?
Because that's real life with data models
that's evolved over a period of time.
Instead of rolling out new columns,
sometimes people change the
meaning of those columns
as they put in new data
types data into them.
And we're gonna focus on
securing our database,
making sure that we do
this in a secure way.
Because it's, you're opening
up your database to an LLM.
To me as an old school database
person, that scares me.
So I wanna make sure that we're
doing this in a secure way
and different things that we
could put in along the way
to make sure that what
it's doing with the data
is only what you intend it to do.
So we don't want it to be
able to just query everything
and post it out to the internet,
that if somebody has some
prompt injection attacks,
how do we protect from
those sort of things.
So let's start writing some code.
All right.
So this is our application.
Let's...
Right? So we won't be in
this screen very much.
So this is just the basic thing.
So just a heads up.
Right at the end of the session,
I'm gonna put a QR code to a GitHub repo
that's gonna have all the code
that we're gonna write today.
So this way you guys could go download it,
I'll upload it when I get
back home after re:Invent,
probably on Monday, right?
But I'll post it all there.
But this way you'll get
everybody'll have the link for it.
Right?
So let's just kind of show
you a little bit what it is.
So this the simple Streamlit app.
So it has a simple login
page. Nothing crazy.
So we have a list of movies, right?
And then we have our MCP server there.
What time is it?
And if we have a decent
internet connection,
everything's gonna sit
there, it returns the time.
So that all seems to be
working just fine. Okay?
Now, our data model here,
this is our list of tables.
Primarily what we're gonna be
looking at is the titles table
that has really all the
information in there.
So it has a handful of columns
in there, has a primary key,
a title type, the title,
start year, end year,
a bunch of indexes, foreign keys, right?
The other thing that we
have here is on this,
I added descriptions for
everything that's there.
Inside of Postgre, using
the comment command here,
we could put in a
description that's there.
The MCP servers can use
that in order to have
the right context of what's in there.
So that's something that, you know,
when you're working
with developers or DBAs,
everybody kind of knows what's
in all the different columns.
And we need to be able to share
that knowledge with the LLMs
using the native tools inside of Postgre
that allows you to put
comments and everything,
lets you really be able
to jump into and do that.
So like you have things
like here, end year,
like, only TV series is
gonna have an end year.
It's null for all everything else.
So having that sort of
information in there,
so this way the LLMs know about it.
Or this one here, the TS vector
for the full tech search for Postgre.
Putting a description of what it is
and even how to use it, right?
So this way, the LLM knows
how to use that sort of column
right, so outside of just
for LLM, that's a great way
for sharing that
knowledge with developers.
If you need to be able to, you know,
tell everybody what's in your schema.
Use comments.
We put it inside our source code.
Put it on your database objects too.
You can put 'em on... pretty
much, inside of Postgre,
you could put it on basically
every type of object
to use it.
Right.
So let's start by creating a...
there's a little lag
here with the internet.
So we'll go create that.
So we're gonna use Kiro to do
all our heavy lifting today.
And we have a couple MCP servers that I...
Did I?
There we go.
So there's some built in.
We have the Postgre MCP server,
and we have the weather MCP server,
just as something to be able to do it,
make sure that MCP is working.
What is the whether in Vegas?
And the cool thing that in Kiro,
it actually asks you whether or not
you want to do a lot of operations
is based on whether or
not it's trusted or not.
So it returns back the weather, right?
Cool.
The MCP that you could have weather
and you could have Postgre
all on the same thing, right?
It'll be able to determine
kind of what you want to do.
So I could also say, what tables
can I query?
Right?
It's gonna think for a second,
and then it's gonna say,
Hey, do you want...
I can run this off the information schema
to get the list of tables.
Right?
I'm also doing this to build
up a little context for Kiro
so it knows what tables
that are there, right?
So those are the same
tables that we're seeing
inside of Postgre when we
look at it that it's there.
So let's start with,
you know, when, for me,
I, being a database person,
whenever I'm writing some sort of function
or whatever that has to
pull data from the database,
I start with a query, right?
When I'm using tools
like Kiro or other ones,
I tend to use it the way I code,
in the same order, in the same chunks.
So I start with writing the queries,
and then I start building
around that, right?
A query that returns
all of the...
hopefully the yellow line
could get that typo, right?
Otherwise, like my OCD
would drive me crazy
for some of these things.
All the characters
and the actors who played them
for a given movie title.
So now it's gonna ask,
if you see the schema.
So I'm gonna try,
so this is using one of
the built in MCP tools,
get table schema,
it's gonna get the table definition.
So I'm gonna trust that
because it's a query
that I know and I trust
versus just being able
to run a random thing.
So...
- [Vlad] Quick question.
- Yep.
- Is that actually
calling an MCP server from Kiro?
- [Jim] Yes. Yes it is.
- [Vlad] That is not related to our effort
of pulling data from
movies and weather, right?
- No.
- Weather and movies
are part of our build?
And then what you're
doing is the ID portion
that's reaching out to the database
through a database specific MCP server?
- [Jim] Yeah.
It's using the Aurora Postgre MCP server
that I have pre-configured
connecting to my database.
So I gave it the connection
string user ID password.
So this way it's all set
to connect to a database
in my development environment, right?
So that it's kind of
pulling it live, right?
So it produced a four table join here
using the full tech search that
we're talking about, right?
So we could say, test the query,
and it's gonna go run it.
Do we wanna run it. Sure.
You notice there's a little latency
as it's kind of going there.
So if you're thinking about
doing kind of text to SQL,
keep that in mind.
So queries worked, right?
It's like, here's an improved version
that's going to pull out
some of the JSON elements.
We don't really want that, right?
But the other thing to think about
is it's doing a full
text search on the name,
but The Godfather has multiple things.
They got Godfather, Godfather 2.
We can forget about Godfather 3.
We'll pretend that never happened.
But it will return multiple
things it's coming along, right?
So, you know, let's make it
so this way it only pulls
one, one particular movie.
- [Audience] You wanna explain it?
- Jim Sure.
Put it in there.
Gonna do an explain analyze
and it will show you
the results it explained
while they are there.
So a lot of times what I'm
doing, if it's running slow,
I'll ask it to do that
and say suggest ways to improve the query.
It's pretty good at doing that,
and analyzing Postgre
explain outputs, right?
So it says it's using a GIN index
and a primary key index, right?
So let's change the query to
only return the most popular title
or multiple matches.
Let's see what it does with that.
It wants to check the ratings table
and it's gonna put it in
there as a sub query, right?
I don't like the fact
that it's doing a full text search twice.
So let's have it
to only use full text search once.
So now it's gonna do it as a CTE.
So it could do pretty
sophisticated queries,
but you need to work with it a little bit
in order to kind of massage
it to get to what you want.
But it's the same way that
I would write a query.
It's like you write something
to kind of get the data
and then you switch it
around, optimize it.
So let's just test it again.
I never trust when it's
gonna run SQL directly
if I don't know.
So I always wait then
and check to make sure,
because sometimes it
does weird things, right?
So it works.
So write the query to a...
so what I'm doing is I'm saving
that off that context there,
so this way we could use that later.
One of the things about using these tools,
if something happens and you
lose your session, right,
it loses all the context that's there.
And we want to, as you're doing things,
you want to build things up,
save it off for a little while,
be able to use that again later, right?
So as I finish one little
piece of it, it's like,
I wanna save off that file
so this way I could use it
as we're building up the bigger solution.
There's a lot of tools.
We saw them in the keynote this morning
about being able to do it
in a much broader thing.
But as you're kind of
learning and being able to,
you start using these tools,
it's a lot of times using it
the way you would normally code
and do it that way,
it's a lot easier to start
start being able to learn
how to do those sort of things.
And it's thinking a really long time
to be able to just write
out a simple query.
This happens sometimes.
Probably if you have a
whole bunch of people
who are also using Kiro
in one of the workshops
or something like that.
We have 60,000 people here
probably all playing around
with Kiro all at the same time.
- [Audience] Where's
your MPC server hosted?
- [Jim] Sorry?
- [Audience] Where's
this MCP server hosted?
- [Jim] Right now, it's
just in a subdirectory
for my application.
- So it's local?
- It's local, yeah. So-
(audience member speaking
indistinctly away from microphone)
- [Vlad] No.
The MCP server does not
call an LLM by itself.
(audience member speaking
indistinctly away from microphone)
- [Vlad] Kiro. Absolutely, yes.
Yeah.
- And one more thing.
How do you preserve the sessions over?
(audience member speaking
indistinctly away from microphone)
You come back day two, you
want to preserve the session.
That's what you were saying, right?
How to remember this session
in Kiro itself, right?
- Yeah.
- Then what did you do
specifically to save that?
- [Jim] This one, I just
told it to write the query
to a file, right?
So just write, so the prompt I gave it
was write the query to a file
called Query1.sql, right?
So this way it's just saving
off the query that we built.
- [Audience] So the plan here is that
if you're building it in
multiple days, this one,
you just leave the Kiro IDE open.
- [Jim] Yeah.
For the way that I'm using
it now, using the CLI,
there's other more sophisticated tools
to have longer term memory.
Maybe Vlad knows some of the ones.
He tends to use those things
a little bit more than I do.
I'm going beyond VI right now.
So this is sophisticated for me.
- [Vlad] You're using the Kiro ID
and you do have access to
multiple sessions, threads,
and are able to switch between them
and keep different contexts
for different tasks and so on.
- [Jim] So we're gonna
write our other query now,
write a query that returns all the roles
and the movie titles
for a given actor.
And it had its context before.
So it's writing a query a lot faster
using that same sort of thing.
But we also put that in the comment there.
So this way it knows that I'm
thinking it should use that.
So we'll test it again, make
sure that's all working.
Things usually work,
but sometimes it makes
some syntactical changes,
little typos.
Sometimes it guides off
into some weird loop, right?
It all depends really
on what the context is.
It seems like it's, right now it's trying
to figure some things out
because it's trying to
run it multiple times.
- [Audience] While you're waiting for it,
can I ask another question?
So is this MCP server, not this one,
the one that we are building,
the MCP server that we are building
that is, your plan is
actually to write a SQL
and then wrap it in the MCP
as the name function, right?
- Yep.
- And give a description.
And that's how it's going
to, LLM is gonna know,
hey, if I want to have movies,
movie list is your MCP
server's target definition
or something like that?
And then you have a SQL behind it.
- [Jim] Yeah, exactly.
So we're gonna write those two tools.
And so we need two SQL queries.
Each one of those tools is gonna pull data
from the database.
I've always done database stuff.
So I think in terms of
write the query first
and then wrap it.
Other people start with the API, right?
And then figure out the
other direction, right?
That's just the way that I tend to code.
Others people think about it differently.
But you could do it either way.
But that's just the way I'd rather do it.
- [Audience] When you have the next break,
I'll ask my next question,
follow up question as well.
- [Jim] So it seems like
there's something wrong here
with the connection.
So I'm just gonna write the context out.
- [Vlad] What Jim is trying to do here
is essentially called
the canned query pattern.
- Yeah.
- So...
- That.
- We're essentially
taking queries, wrapping them into tools,
and they become deterministic tools.
That is with this Aurora MCP server,
you can always ask it by hand,
hey, give me this data
from here, here and here.
But what's happening behind the scenes is
the MCP agent's gonna think about
trying to discover the schema,
figuring out what tables to ask,
what joints it might need to make,
and then come up with a query.
A query may work or may not work.
It'll test it.
So you're going through a
lot of agent loop cycles
just to find the right query.
Which works if you're just
doing data exploration, right?
But if you're writing it
for a front end application,
you probably don't want
that type of a complexity,
let alone latency.
So the application's
gonna call, predictably,
a certain set of deterministic queries.
So let's take those queries,
wrap 'em into tools,
and then expose them to any end users.
And that's what we're trying to do here.
But we're starting with the queries.
- [Jim] Yeah.
- [Audience] One way to do it
is to expose it as tools, right?
So each and every query that you need,
you want to expose those tools.
The other way is, why
can't you basically say,
these are the tables that are available
along with the metadata
that he already had, right?
And then let the LLM
decide how to join those.
- [Vlad] You absolutely can,
but there's two practical
implications there, right?
Who are the users of that tool?
If it's you or Jim in front of there,
then he can afford to go in
and let the LLM figure out the query.
That's perfectly fine, right?
That's the purpose here.
I imagine there's 10,000
of Jims sitting there
and doing that.
At that scale, does that
make sense anymore, right?
No, because then you're
consuming a lot of tokens,
it's gonna be very, very costly for you
to offer that capability.
But if you know that the people are always
going to ask the question
about the actors,
go ahead and take that query,
wrap it around into its own tool,
and it's gonna always going
to call that single tool.
It doesn't need to go through
multiple loops of the LLM.
It doesn't need to consume extra tokens.
It doesn't need to wait
and have extra latency.
So there's a trade off there, right?
But what Jim is doing there
is giving him flexibility
to design the right tools.
But if this would be an
agent that I would be using
as a consumer,
that wouldn't be cost effective
for whoever is operating that service.
So Jim is building the tools for me,
essentially, as a consumer.
- [Audience] You can basically say
with the default local MCP server,
you can let it query the schema
and say write an MCP server,
because that's also an element, right,
write an MCP server, look at these tables,
but have the tools defined
as one for movie and one for actors.
Write an MCP server with two tools, right?
- [Vlad] Yeah, yeah.
You can absolutely design that way.
Or it can be a thousand queries or tools.
It doesn't matter,
right? It's the use case.
- [Audience] What is an optimal runtime.
(audience member speaking
indistinctly away from microphone)
- [Vlad] Correct. Yeah.
- [Jim] So writing a prompt now
to really write the MCP server.
So I'm telling it I
want to have two tools.
I gave it a reference to
the weather MCP server
as a template.
It does a lot better if
you point it at something
of what you basically
wanna look like, right,
in order to do that,
telling it to connect to the database
using "Psycho." PG3,
use the queries that we
generate as templates.
And then we wanna load
the connection information
from my file called .env.
Now it's gonna think
about that for a second,
and it's gonna want to go check that tool,
that other MCP server, so
we can see what's there.
It's gonna go find those queries.
Now it's gonna build that MCP server
writing a lot of Python code
a lot faster than I could do it, right?
Than I could type it, right?
So this is what it's given us, right?
It's movie server creating a
database connection, right?
It's only getting a database URL.
We need to change that, right?
Here it's pulling in that
query that we had, right?
Here's the other one, pulling
in the other query, right?
And then it's the main thing.
So let's tell it to change
the get DB connection.
Like user and password.
Instead of a full URL.
It'd much rather have distinct things.
So this way you have to go
change your password, right?
Or you should do this thing
instead of having the
full connection string.
It's just the way I'd prefer it.
So let's see if it did that, right?
Right. There we go, right?
Pulling that all together that way.
So we say, yeah, let's save that off.
All right.
So now let's... now we
have this movie server.
We'll copy the .env file here.
And let's get outta here
and let's test that out.
Gotta go up one more.
Now, if we could go
through this whole session
with this thing producing no errors,
it would be the first time ever
I've run through this thing.
So I'm anticipating
something going wrong, right?
Especially since it's,
you know, things are non-deterministic.
As a database person,
that drives me a little crazy, right?
Because you don't know
what you're gonna get.
Let's see in Star Wars.
Alright?
And because it knows what Star Wars is,
it just pulled it off the internet, right?
So it, we didn't fix.
You need to be able to tell the user app
to be able to use it.
Let's go back to Kiro here.
Change.
Directory.
So the way I tend to
interact with these things,
with the prompts, it's
just the same way as if
I was talking to somebody
next to me and trying to,
like, have them code for me, right?
Assuming my fingers weren't working
if I was gonna have somebody do it
that kind of knows how to
code a little bit, right?
And extracting 'em, it's
like... it tends to work.
- [Vlad] You're a backseat
coder there, basically.
- [Jim] Yeah. Yeah.
It's that, that's definitely what it is.
I'm really embracing the
two person coding rule there
and having somebody
else do all the typing.
As everybody's seeing, I'm
a terrible typer, right?
So now we're adding that in there.
Added that second MCP server.
All right.
Let's go try that again.
But that's kind of how we're using it too,
even inside of RDS
and how everybody's
starting to use these tools.
It's kind of a paired programming thing
for a lot of people in
order to really accelerate
your development program.
Now, let's see if we could find that tool.
There we go.
Found the tool. Get movie characters.
So it's running the query
in the background, right?
Gets back the list of them
there and then it displays it.
So that's something there
that is out on the internet.
So you know, it's not
really showing anything
because it is kind of public.
So let's go create something there
that's not there, right?
So I have this simple
app here called admin.
Instead of you watching
me write a bunch of stuff
inside of SQL,
just basic thing over top of it.
So let's create a new movie called DAT429
Coding an MCP Server.
And we will make this a TV movie.
We'll add a person. So add Jim.
Come on. Go.
No, there we go.
Okay, let's add Vlad.
Now let's put them in that movie.
Jim.
Everybody in the Postgre
community calls me Jimbo.
So let's, that's the character name,
and let's go Vlad.
And we got Mr. Vlad over there in the back
with the microphone.
So now we have a movie there
that's not out on the internet.
And I just killed my session there, right?
I know Streamlit's still running.
It is.
Let's kill this sucker.
Let's see if we could go find that movie
that we just created.
Because that's only gonna
be in our database, right?
Same as if you had your
own internal stuff.
That's not, the models haven't
been trained on, right?
Who is in the movie?
DAT429
Boom. Was able to find that.
So this way it had enough reference there
to be able to know, hey, it's a movie.
Let the movie tool so this
way you could get that.
It doesn't have to go out
the internet to get it.
It's pulling off my local database.
So even though we're using
public information there,
a lot of times you
wanna build these tools,
these MCP tools using
your own internal stuff
that you're not training public models on,
but you still want people
to interact with, right?
But how do we secure this stuff, right?
This is still, if you're putting
this out on the internet,
right, or if you wanna be able
to do that, you wanna be able
to secure that a little bit better, right?
- [Vlad] One comment I would make there is
the LLM is not necessarily
going out on the internet
and doing a search.
So whenever Jim searched for Star Wars,
Star Wars was part of a training data set
for the model itself.
So it, when the LLM got invoked,
it figured that it can answer
that question directly
without invoking any tools.
- [Jim] Yeah.
(audience member speaking
indistinctly away from microphone)
- [Vlad] Well, the first
time when Jim asked
for Star Wars, gimme the
characters for Star Wars,
the LLM actually didn't go
through any sort of tools.
It simply just answered,
it generated the answer
because it had... it most
likely, it's such a popular thing
that it was most likely
in the training data set
for that particular model
that is used underneath Kiro.
But in this case, right, this wasn't.
So that's when it decided
that this is potentially
an obscure enough movie
that it needs to use
the tool to access it.
(audience member speaking
indistinctly away from microphone)
It's non-deterministic.
So there is no, it's not a rule that says,
Hey, first ask your tools and then do,
if you can't do the other thing.
When the agent sends that
particular prompt to the LLM,
the LLM is going to decide
what is the best course of action.
That's it.
You have no control
over that at that point.
You might have control
using steering documents.
And so using the prompt itself,
you could potentially tell it,
Hey, always look for this
information in the tools
before answering.
Or you can do that, but
even then you don't have
a full guarantee that
it will do that, right?
Fundamentally what the LLM responds back
is going to be relatively
non-deterministic, right?
- [Jim] So let's... no,
go ahead this question.
- Alright, this is an
inter interesting topic.
When doing stuff with MCP,
is it possible to create sort
of like a shadow of knowledge
by having the agent select
a specific MCP server
to ask for a solution
that it already would
have access in the model,
and so therefore you
could make it not aware
of certain things?
- [Vlad] Maybe. (laughing)
Yeah, that's the answer.
You can tell the MCP
server to use certain tools
and within certain frameworks
of building agents,
you can define what some
of the steps are in that.
So for example, if you would be using
something like line graph,
you can define nodes that need
to be transitioned through
before it goes to the
LLM for the decision.
So in those situations,
you could force a step at the beginning,
Hey, always look here
right, into this data set,
before you invoke the LLM.
But that's not MCP that's enforcing that,
that's not your tool
that's enforcing that.
That's the way you're
building the agent itself
that does that.
- [Jim] Yeah, a lot of that stuff,
it's how do you force some
determinism into something
that's inherently
non-deterministic, right?
It's, you have to force
it in some way, right?
And that's kind of what
we're gonna show here
a little bit too, of like,
how do we lock down some of this data
based off the user
that's logged in, right?
So, you know, if we look
here at this titles table,
there's 11 million entries in there.
But you know, for this
one we wanna lock it down
by the title type that, you know,
Jim could only see title
type of one, that's movies.
Vlad could see them all,
and test two could see one in five, right?
It's like we're using that for titles.
A lot of times you might have a tenant ID
or some other determining factor
of who could see what data, right?
Based on some roles, right?
So using that, we could see if we have
this sort of where clause
where title type equals any,
because this is a Postgre array, right?
We have 700,000 titles in there.
Movie titles, one in five,
we have 872,000 those.
So it's like that's
kind of the where clause
that we want to inherently
have all the time.
Putting that something
inside of the MCP server
and being able to pass that thing there,
it's like having the LLM put
the right thing in there.
We can never trust that.
So we wanna make it in a
more deterministic way.
So tools like Postgre have that ability.
So what we want to do is
use row level security
in order to be able to lock that down.
So let's go do that.
So what I'm gonna do is
set an environment variable
inside of Postgre
so this way we could start
building what we want
for our policy to be.
So there's a function called
set_config that'll set that.
So this way now we could go here
and instead of having that string,
we'll get the current setting.
So now we set that to just having one.
So that should match our 719,000 rows.
So this way now, this is
really the where clause
that we want to set.
So this way, based off what we set
that RLS typed environment
variable to, right?
That where clause automatically
gets appended to it.
Read policy ROS
types on titles,
using.
I always copy and paste this where clause.
Okay?
Alter table titles.
Enable row level security.
Okay?
Now we are currently running
as the table's owner.
So row level security won't apply to that.
So let's connect as the MCP user,
not as the MCP owner, right?
Now if we do just this one.
So when we run that is
that you get nothing,
because we have nothing set.
So when you set, you create your policy
for something like role level
security, you wanna make it
so this way if things aren't
set, you get no data, right?
So now we want to explicitly allow
to be able to see some of that.
So we'll go back and set
the config here, right?
And now we could do that again
without putting that where
clause in there, right?
And we wait that and now we
get the right answer there.
So row level security with Postgre.
So automatically add that in there.
So when we're thinking about
things like context like MCP
or things where you're not
quite sure what's gonna happen
as things get passed in there,
we want to add that determinism in there,
especially around securing your data.
Things like if you're in the Oracle world,
virtual private database,
there's things like that.
There's other ways of doing
that inside the database
that we could be sure that's there, right?
So now let's use those,
those tools that's there.
So let's go into the movie server.
So we'll go back to Kiro.
Change the...
So what I'm gonna do is to take in
command line parameter
because that's how this MCP
server is taking things in
through standard IO,
and I'm telling you kind
of what library to use.
Value to call.
Set_config.
Right after making a database connection.
Use the following as a template.
You notice I'm always
telling it to use a template
because I usually try these things
and then once I know it's gonna work,
I don't let it try to
figure it out a second time.
I just tell it how to do it, right?
Ends up being a lot faster that way
instead of it trying to figure it out.
So pulled that import in there,
set that to none,
right after the connection,
we're gonna call that with the value
that it gets passed in.
Yep. We're gonna allow that,
merge that patch, right?
And now it's parsing, getting titles type.
Yep, we want that.
Cool.
So now let's go change
parent directory
to pass title types
to the MCP server.
Load entitled_types
from the user table
when logging in.
Let's see what it does with that.
It's always an adventure with this seeing
what it's going to kind of code,
it's gonna spit out at me, right?
It's you need to be able to
look at things along the way.
Yeah, we'll trust this.
Yep.
Wants to be able to go see that. Sure.
So added that into select,
that's getting there,
but that's coming back as a Postgre array.
Python doesn't handle that so well.
So exchange the query to cast
entitled_types as a text.
We want that coming back as a string
so it's easier to pass around.
That one I've run through a bunch of times
and run a bunch of errors.
So just save everybody
the time that I know
we have to cast that as a text.
Right now it's putting it in the session.
Now it's passing in the
ARGs that are there.
Right? So this is another
thing that I noticed.
Because this thing is in a
different memory context there,
it's not gonna have access
to that session, right?
So this is another one of those things
I keep bumping into, right?
So change it so entitled
is passed to the args
as a local variable.
I haven't tried this prompt
yet. We'll see what happens.
I just know that that
code that it spit out
is gonna be a problem, right?
There we go. We put it
there, put it in there.
That looks like it'll
work a little bit better.
Cool.
Now we gotta go up one.
Here we go.
This is taking a lot longer, right?
So, and it's not spitting out
any movies or anything there.
Because we have the row level security.
We didn't set change user_app.py
in order to handle the row level security.
We're just passing it to the MCP server.
Okay?
DAT429.
So calling the tool, right?
Couldn't find it, right?
It's 'cause when we created
DAT429 that, that movie,
we set it as a type of a TV
movie, not a regular movie,
which has a code of five instead of one.
Jim only has access to,
only has access to titles of one.
So if we log in as Vlad.
Vlad, I stole your password.
- [Vlad] Oh no.
- [Jim] Now Vlad has
access to all the types.
Still couldn't find it.
Maybe that's a session thing.
Can tell this isn't a pre-can demo
because the the cool stuff didn't run.
Let's try this guy, see if that one works.
Test two.
Still couldn't find it.
So the sucker is locked
down pretty good, right?
Not quite sure where that's going that,
but there, there's...
being able to pass in the determinism here
is something that the LLM
isn't gonna be able to do.
That's why we're passing it in here
through logging it in, right?
So getting it there and then
passing it in down here.
So it's probably that I'm
not passing it in through
this entitled types properly.
Right? It's probably this sort of thing.
Let's just put it here
and that's probably
gonna give us an error,
but let's try that.
- [Vlad] This is the point
where I would honestly try logging.
(pair laughing)
See what the variables are, or you know.
- [Jim] Try mocking.
- Yeah.
Yeah, we could, but we only
have a few minutes left.
So go going ahead and
trying to go through that
and having it go do all that is...
It is a little finicky
about how you pass some of that through.
- [Vlad] It did it?
- [Jim] Yeah, there's the error.
So that's the error that
I was trying to avoid.
All right.
Where I can't find that key,
the missing key here, right?
So that comes down to
Python Streamlit stuff
that I don't really want to
debug in front of everybody here
because I don't know
where that's gonna go.
And we ask Kiro, it's gonna
go off into little tangents,
but the main idea there of
using row level security
in order to lock down your data,
because that's the deterministic part.
If the LLM is passing
something that's there,
it has policies that, as you could see,
you get no data if it's sending
things in the wrong way.
That's what you want the default to be
is don't expose out your
data in some sort of way.
You'd rather it get no data
than putting out the wrong data.
As we're using these tools
and it's moving faster and faster,
we have to remember good security
practices around our data
and the privacy and the aspect of that.
So it means leveraging the
features inside the database
in order to be able to do that.
Because those are the deterministic parts.
If we added another parameter
to the tools that's passed in,
like the user ID or the entitled types,
maybe the LLM will put it in there, right?
Maybe it won't, right?
It might just say, hey, I
want access to all the movies.
So then it'll try to
log in as Vlad, right?
It's like it'll pass
in like a random string
that I'll give you all the
things that are there, but...
Right. That's the main thing that's there.
Let me flip back over here so as...
As we get...
That QR code goes to the GitHub repo
that I'll post this code that's up there.
I will get it working, right,
with that last little bit
and I'll leave comments in the code
of what I changed from what
we have here in our session.
So this way everybody
could see that's there
of what did it quite do
wrong with passing that thing
and that entitled types parameter across.
But for folks who are doing that
you'll be able to see it
and you'll be able to run everything.
I also have scripts on
how to create the database
of downloading the files,
being able to recreate
everything that we did.
It'll be in that GitHub repo
probably Monday morning.
When you're doing it in
development environment.
We saw a lot of the loops
as we were going here.
But if that was your main
production application,
you have a basically
the internet doing there
that all of a sudden
if they ask questions,
all of a sudden your bill
goes through the roof.
And you have no way of
determining that, right?
It's like it becomes a problem.
So like Vlad said,
it's if you're sure
you're gonna need that context
every time, just add it.
- Yep.
- Right.
We, Vlad and I did a code
talk of last year about RAG
where it was more deterministic
of doing some of that stuff
where we took movies,
created a JSON document,
it put putting vectors on it
and then used that for semantic,
for nearest neighbor
searches and stuff like that.
For semantic searches was
more deterministic than this,
but it was less flexible
because we had to pre-can all
the vectors ahead of the time.
So if we were gonna add the movie,
we had to go create the
vector of that new movie,
put it into, decide the database
in order for it to find it.
This is just using standard SQL.
Thank you everybody.
Please fill out the survey.
It really helps us in order
to make everything better for you.
So please fill out the survey
and leave some comments for us.
Even if it just says hi.
That would be cool too.
Appreciate it. Thanks everybody.
- [Vlad] Thank you all.
(audience applauding)